This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. It's one of the most common tropes in Hollywood. It seems the tables have turned, Mr. Powers. The classic turning of the tables. When the person at the bottom of the heap suddenly has all the power. When I left you, I was but alone. Now I am the master. Or the unassuming guy with glasses ends up being the superhero.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是好莱坞最常见的桥段之一。看来局势逆转了，鲍尔斯先生。经典的局势逆转。当处于社会底层的人突然掌握了所有权力。我离开你时，我只是孤身一人。现在我是主人了。或者那个戴眼镜的普通人最终成为了超级英雄。
You mean you think I'm Superman? I'm willing to bet my life on. Lois, you are priced. There's a reason the storytelling technique is so popular. It allows characters to break out of the box we've put them in. It allows us to see them in a new light. Today, we decided to turn the tables on me. We're going to bring you a conversation I had with Chris Boyd,
你是说你觉得我是超人？我愿意拿我的生命打赌。露易丝，你被高估了。这种叙事手法之所以如此受欢迎是有原因的。它让角色能够打破我们给他们设定的框架。它让我们以全新的视角看待他们。今天，我们决定把局势逆转到我身上。我们将为你带来我与克里斯·博伊德的对话，
host of the public radio show Think at KERA in Dallas. She'll be interviewing me about my most recent book, Useful Delusions. This week on Hidden Brain, the delusions that keep couples happily married, the rituals that help patients heal, and the self-deceptions that hold nations together. Lots of bad things can come from our failure to accept reality. We find ourselves in denial of our bad habits, we fall for cons, we make choices based less on facts than on what we wish to be true.
她是达拉斯KERA电台公共广播节目《思考》的主持人。她将采访我关于我的最新著作《有用的错觉》。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨让夫妻幸福美满的错觉、帮助病人康复的仪式，以及维系国家团结的自我欺骗。如果我们无法接受现实，很多糟糕的事情就会发生。我们发现自己否认坏习惯，我们上当受骗，我们做出的选择更多是基于我们希望什么是真的，而不是基于事实。
It seems like evolution might have done away with our tendency for self-deception a long time ago. Since that hasn't happened, it's worth asking, are there benefits to our sometimes slippery grasp on the truth? From Keira Indalist, this is Hank, I'm Chris Boyd. Journalist Shankar Vianantam is host of the Hidden Brain podcast.
看来进化可能很久以前就应该消除我们自我欺骗的倾向了。既然这种情况没有发生，那么值得一问的是，我们这种有时对真相把握不准的状态是否有益处？来自KERA的《思考》，我是克里斯·博伊德。记者尚卡尔·维丹塔姆是《隐藏的大脑》播客的主持人。
As a guy who prides himself on seeking truth through the objective and rational assessment of facts, he has been curious about the ways we all side-step reality from time to time, seeing what we wish to see as individual actors and as members of groups. So he's that up to understand why we do it, and discover that sometimes fooling ourselves can be good for us.
作为一个以通过客观和理性评估事实来追求真理而自豪的人，他一直对我们所有人不时回避现实、作为个体和群体成员只看我们想看的东西的方式感到好奇。所以他着手去理解我们为什么这样做，并发现有时自欺欺人对我们是有好处的。
He explains all this in his book, Useful Delusions, the Power and Paradox of the Self-Deseaving Brain. Shankar, welcome back to Think. Thank you so much, Chris. I'm delighted to be here. The genesis of this reporting was actually a true crime story that seemed to make no sense to you. Tell us about Donald Lowry and how he managed to have his victims showing up to defend him. It's a fascinating story. Donald Lowry was a balding, middle-aged man living in a very small town in Illinois.
他在他的书《有用的错觉：自欺大脑的力量与悖论》中解释了这一切。尚卡尔，欢迎回到《思考》。非常感谢，克里斯。很高兴来到这里。这篇报道的起源实际上是一个在你看来毫无意义的真实犯罪故事。告诉我们关于唐纳德·洛瑞的事，以及他是如何让受害者站出来为他辩护的。这是一个引人入胜的故事。唐纳德·洛瑞是一个住在伊利诺伊州一个小镇上的秃顶中年男子。
And over a period of a couple of decades, he invented various characters, young women whom he called angels. He invented their personas. And then wrote love letters in their voices to thousands of men across the United States. Some of these love letters were sent to these men over a period of years, sometimes decades. The members, the men who received these letters were said to be part of a group that Don Lowry called the Church of Love. And over the course of many years, these men who often wrote back to the women whom they thought were writing to them, sometimes fell in love with their correspondence and believed they had found their soulmates. The most remarkable part of the story is not the con itself, but when the con was unmasked and Don Lowry was brought to trial on charges of mail fraud.
在几十年的时间里，他发明了各种角色，他称之为“天使”的年轻女性。他虚构了她们的人格。然后以她们的声音给美国各地的数千名男性写情书。其中一些情书在几年甚至几十年的时间里被寄给这些男人。收到这些信的男人们据说是一个唐·洛瑞称之为“爱之教会”的组织成员。多年来，这些男人经常回信给他们以为正在给他们写信的女性，有时会爱上他们的通信对象，并相信他们找到了灵魂伴侣。这个故事最引人注目的部分不是骗局本身，而是当骗局被揭穿，唐·洛瑞因邮件欺诈罪受审时。
Some of the members of the Church of Love were so upset that the operation was going to be shut down that they showed up at a courtroom in peoria to defend down lorry to keep the con going and i found this such an amazing story that when the con is revealed the marks show up to defend the con man that it prompted me to look deeper at the nature of self deception yes so you thought was it possible this con had done something beneficial for the people who got scammed? Exactly. Now, there were a variety of people who reacted in different ways.
“爱之教会”的一些成员对行动将被关闭感到非常不安，以至于他们出现在皮奥里亚的法庭上为唐·洛瑞辩护，试图让骗局继续下去。我发现这是一个如此惊人的故事：当骗局被揭穿时，受害者竟然站出来为骗子辩护，这促使我更深入地研究自我欺骗的本质。是的，所以你当时想，这个骗局是否对那些被骗的人产生了一些有益的影响？正是如此。当然，有各种各样的人以不同的方式做出了反应。
There were people who reacted in the very predictable way of being upset that they had gotten conned, and they were outraged to down Lowry. But at his trial, there were numerous people who testified for both the defense and the prosecution who said that the letters from these angels had kept them from depression. A couple of people said the letters had saved them from suicide. And so it prompted me to rethink my views about this very strange story and ask myself at least for some members, is it possible that some elements of the Church of Love did play a salutary role?
有些人以非常可预测的方式做出了反应，对被骗感到不安，并对唐·洛瑞感到愤怒。但在他的审判中，有许多人为辩方和控方作证，他们说这些“天使”的来信使他们免于抑郁。有几个人说这些信件甚至挽救了他们的生命，使他们免于自杀。因此，这促使我重新思考我对这个非常奇怪的故事的看法，并问自己，至少对一些成员来说，是否有可能“爱之教会”的某些元素确实发挥了有益的作用？
We should talk about a bias many of us hold against people we see as having engaged in self-deception or having been conned. You say the ability to not be self-deceiving is not necessarily a sign of great intelligence, it's a sign of privilege. That's right. So when I first thought about the story of the Church of Love, I looked at it I think the way most of us would look at that story from the outside, which is we think about the people who fell for the scorn as being deluded fools, gullible people Simpletons perhaps and and you know I certainly had those views about the members of the Church of love
我们应该谈谈我们许多人对那些被视为参与自我欺骗或被骗的人所持有的偏见。你说不自欺欺人的能力并不一定标志着高智商，而是一种特权。没错。所以当我第一次想到“爱之教会”的故事时，我想我以大多数人从外部看待那个故事的方式来看待它，即我们认为那些上当受骗的人是受骗的傻瓜、轻信的人，也许是笨蛋，而且你知道，我当然对“爱之教会”的成员有这些看法。
But it's I got to know some of them and interview them and greater depth I started to have more compassion for them. I started to understand the life circumstances that prompted them to compassion for them. I started to understand the life circumstances that prompted them to turn to such a con and to believe in it. And then I started to ask myself the question, is this true of my own life? When I experience vulnerabilities, when I experience anxieties, if there are things that greatly worry me, things that I have no control over, do I start to reach for beliefs in some ways that soothe my own anxieties, that in some ways relieve me from my fears and my worries? And I found that I do this too, and there's a wide variety of psychological research that shows that when we are in the grip of fear or terror or anxiety or loneliness, we are far
但当我开始了解他们中的一些人并深入采访他们时，我开始对他们产生同情。我开始理解促使他们转向这种骗局并相信它的生活环境。然后我开始问自己一个问题，这在我自己的生活中是否也适用？当我经历脆弱、经历焦虑时，如果有些事情让我非常担心，有些事情我无法控制，我是否会开始寻求某种方式来缓解我自己的焦虑，在某种程度上减轻我的恐惧和担忧？我发现我也会这样做，而且有大量的心理学研究表明，当我们处于恐惧、惊恐、焦虑或孤独的控制之下时，我们远
more likely to reach for beliefs that allow us to cope. There's the old proverb, there are no atheists in the foxhole. And I think that sums up the idea that in some ways when you're outside the foxhole, when you don't have bullets whizzing over your head, it's easy to look down with contempt at the beliefs that people come up with in those situations. But you and I, to actually be in that situation ourselves, many of us might turn to very similar delusions. I think a lot of people might be listening and still thinking, well, that happens to other people, but I have a firm grasp on reality.
更有可能寻求那些让我们能够应对的信念。有句老话，战壕里没有无神论者。我认为这总结了这样一种观点：在某种程度上，当你不在战壕里，当你没有子弹在头顶呼啸而过时，很容易轻视人们在那种情况下产生的信念。但如果你我真的处于那种境地，我们许多人可能会转向非常相似的错觉。我想很多人可能在听的时候还在想，好吧，那是发生在别人身上的事，但我对现实有坚定的把握。
But you remind us that every second our eyes are opening, are open. We're experiencing some kind of self-deception. Yeah, so when we think about delusion and self-deception, I think we think about it at the level of these large cons or the level of conspiracy theories. And, you know, we certainly can talk about self-deception and delusion at the level of conspiracy theories, but in some ways it helps to actually take a step back and look at much more everyday examples of how our brain operates. I mentioned the example in the book that in any given moment you know our eyes taken about a billion bits of information, but if all this information was actually transmitted to the brain we actually would very quickly get overwhelmed by the amount of information coming in. And so our brains engage in a significant amount of filtering. By the time the information
但你提醒我们，我们睁开眼睛的每一秒，都在经历某种自我欺骗。是的，所以当我们想到错觉和自我欺骗时，我想我们想到的是大规模骗局或阴谋论层面的东西。而且，你知道，我们当然可以谈论阴谋论层面的自我欺骗和错觉，但在某种程度上，退后一步看看我们大脑运作的更日常的例子实际上是有帮助的。我在书中提到了一个例子，在任何给定的时刻，你知道我们的眼睛接收大约十亿比特的信息，但如果所有这些信息都真正传输到大脑，我们实际上会很快被涌入的信息量所淹没。所以我们的大脑进行了大量的过滤。当信息
actually gets to the brain it's been reduced a thousand fold, only a million bits of information actually get to the brain. And then the brain actually processes only about 40 bits of this of these million bits of information. So out of the billion you began with, the brain basically is processing about 40. And this is how all of us look out and see the world. Now an engineer might say what has happened is in fact a profound delusion because what you see, what your experience of sight is in fact so far distant from the reality that's coming flooding into your eyes. But from a functional perspective, this is exactly how the brain needs to operate. The brain has learned through many, many millions of years of evolution that in some ways all this filtering
真正到达大脑时，它已经被减少了一千倍，只有一百万比特的信息真正到达大脑。然后大脑实际上只处理这百万比特信息中的大约40比特。所以从你开始的十亿比特中，大脑基本上只处理了大约40比特。这就是我们所有人观察和看待世界的方式。现在一位工程师可能会说，所发生的事情实际上是一种深刻的错觉，因为你所看到的，你的视觉体验，实际上与涌入你眼睛的现实相去甚远。但从功能角度来看，这正是大脑需要运作的方式。大脑通过数百万年的进化了解到，在某种程度上，所有这些过滤
while it might not show us reality is actually quite functional. Let me give you another example. I just finished eating some food that was really delicious and I realized as I was chewing my food that the experience of deliciousness is itself a delusion because of course food itself does not have taste, sugar does not taste sweet. Those are experiences and perceptions that are layered on to the sensations coming from our tongue by the brain. So you could argue that the brain in some ways is inventing the experience of sweetness when we eat something sweet or we eat something delicious.
虽然可能没有向我们展示现实，但实际上是非常实用的。让我再给你举个例子。我刚吃了一些非常美味的食物，我在咀嚼食物时意识到，美味的体验本身就是一种错觉，因为当然食物本身没有味道，糖尝起来并不甜。那些是大脑叠加在舌头传来的感觉上的体验和感知。所以你可以说，大脑在某种程度上是在我们吃甜食或吃美味的东西时发明了甜味或美味的体验。
But you can see again how this can be very functional. The delusions we have about what we are eating can prompt us in the direction of certain kinds of foods, which of course is why our brains are designed to perceive taste in the first place. I've been endlessly fascinated by the research that finds that the people who are most accurately understanding reality tend to be people who are clinically depressed. What does that suggest about the value of self-deception, at least in some cases, to mental health? This has been a long-standing debate in the field of mental health, Chris. And I think for many years people believed that when you're suffering from an illness, you're seeing the world sort of delusionally, that you're seeing the world, if you have depression, for example, or anxiety, that you're seeing the world with a delusional pessimism, for example. But studies over the last 20 or 30 years have challenged this, and if anything, they find almost the opposite, that people with depression and
但你可以再次看到这如何是非常实用的。我们对所吃食物的错觉可以促使我们选择某些种类的食物，这当然就是为什么我们的大脑被设计成首先感知味道的原因。我一直对那些发现最准确理解现实的人往往是临床抑郁症患者的研究非常着迷。这对于自我欺骗在某些情况下的心理健康价值意味着什么？这是心理健康领域长期以来的争论，克里斯。我认为多年来人们相信，当你患有疾病时，你是在以一种错觉的方式看待世界，即如果你患有抑郁症或焦虑症，你是在以一种错觉的悲观主义看待世界。但过去20或30年的研究挑战了这一点，如果说有什么发现的话，那就是几乎相反的结果，即患有抑郁症和
anxiety and some other mental disorders might in fact be seeing the world more accurately than people who are quote unquote mentally healthy. Part of what it means to be mentally healthy in other words might be that you're able to take in, you know, distressing information, information about threats or dangers that you don't ignore that information, but that you don't let yourself get overwhelmed by that information. Part of being mentally healthy might involve looking at the world through roast into glasses. And of course, this coincides with a lot of other research that has found that in many ways as people cope with various setbacks that they have in life, let's say someone loses a family member
焦虑症以及其他一些精神障碍的人，实际上可能比所谓的“心理健康”的人更准确地看待世界。换句话说，心理健康的部分含义可能是你能够吸收令人痛苦的信息，关于威胁或危险的信息，你不会忽视这些信息，但你不会让自己被这些信息淹没。心理健康的部分可能涉及戴着玫瑰色眼镜看世界。当然，这与许多其他研究相吻合，这些研究发现，在许多方面，当人们应对生活中遇到的各种挫折时，比如某人失去了家庭成员
or suffers a grievous illness, over what follows over the next several months is not necessarily an accurate perception of all that they have lost, but a process of grieving, a process of coping, that in some ways sets aside the tragedy that's happened, sets aside the trauma that's happened, puts it back into a corner of your mind to allow you to go on with the rest of your life. And when that doesn't happen, when the trauma continues in some ways to occupy much of our minds,
或遭受了严重的疾病，随后的几个月里，并不一定是对他们所失去的一切的准确感知，而是一个悲伤的过程，一个应对的过程，在某种程度上将发生的悲剧放在一边，将发生的创伤放在一边，把它放回你大脑的一个角落，让你能够继续你的余生。而当这种情况没有发生，当创伤在某种程度上继续占据我们大部分思想时，
we call those mental illnesses. We say this person is suffering from post-traumatic stress disorder. This person can't let go of the traumatic memories that have happened to them. And we think of being mentally healthy now as helping this person in some ways put the traumas behind them, put them out of sight from their regular perception. You profile a high-end hotel manager here, guy named Jose Trevinio, who is great at his job. a high-end hotel manager here, guy named Jose Trevinio, who is great at his job, in part because he's a master at deception. How does that deception require the buy-in from customers?
我们称之为精神疾病。我们说这个人患有创伤后应激障碍。这个人无法放下发生在他们身上的创伤性记忆。我们现在认为心理健康是帮助这个人以某种方式将创伤抛在脑后，将它们从常规感知中隐藏起来。你在这里介绍了一位高端酒店经理，一个叫何塞·特雷维尼奥的人，他在工作中表现出色。他之所以出色，部分原因是他是一个欺骗大师。这种欺骗如何需要客户的配合？
Well, I think, as I started to look at these concentric circles of self-deception, I started again with sort of these very basic ideas of how the brain operates, but then you start to go up in these concentric circles and you see that something like customer service often involves vast acts of both deception and self deception. Many of us sort of expect courteous service when we are, you know, sitting as passengers in a plane or we are pulling up at a drive-through window or you're showing up at a resort somewhere
嗯，我认为，当我开始审视这些自我欺骗的同心圆时，我再次从大脑运作的一些非常基本的想法开始，但随后你开始进入这些同心圆，你会发现像客户服务这样的事情通常涉及大量的欺骗和自我欺骗行为。我们许多人当作为飞机上的乘客，或者在免下车窗口停车，或者出现在某个度假胜地时，往往期望得到礼貌的服务，
or you go to a restaurant, we expect courteous service. And of course, that's not unreasonable for us to expect courteous service. But the people providing us those courteousies are being asked to provide courteous service, not just to us, but to multiple people for many, many hours of the day. And I don't know when the last time you tried to be courteous to everyone, kind to everyone, interested in what they had to say for eight hours at a time. To smile at everyone you meet, for eight hours at a time, to be polite, to be deferential,
或者你去餐馆，我们期望礼貌的服务。当然，我们期望礼貌的服务并不过分。但为我们提供这些礼貌的人被要求提供礼貌的服务，不仅是对我们，而且是对多个人，每天持续许多小时。我不知道你上次尝试对每个人都礼貌、对每个人都友善、对他们要说的话感兴趣，一次持续八小时是什么时候。对你遇到的每个人微笑，一次持续八小时，要礼貌，要恭敬，
to everyone you meet for many hours on stretch. Anyone who's tried to do this understands that this is actually very difficult to do. It's not what comes naturally, and customer service in some ways involves suppressing the natural urges we might have to, you know, a customer comes up and makes a bizarre request. You know, we might be inclined to tell the customer, you know, that's a ridiculous request and you're an idiot for making it. But of course, we would lose our jobs if we did that.
对你遇到的每个人持续许多小时。任何尝试过这样做的人都明白，这实际上是非常困难的。这不是自然而然的事情，客户服务在某种程度上涉及压制我们可能有的自然冲动，你知道，一个客户走过来提出了一个奇怪的要求。你知道，我们可能倾向于告诉客户，你知道，那是一个荒谬的要求，你提出这个要求真是个白痴。但当然，如果我们那样做，我们就会丢掉工作。
And so we come up with deceptions and we come up with ways to hide how we might truly feel. Now, there's also self-deception involved here because when you go to a restaurant, part of what you're paying for is in fact, the courteous service. You're paying for these courteacies, but there's a fiction that what is being transacted is not someone's deception in exchange for your money.
所以我们想出了欺骗手段，想出了隐藏我们真实感受的方法。现在，这里也涉及自我欺骗，因为当你去餐馆时，你支付的一部分实际上是礼貌的服务。你为这些礼貌付费，但有一个虚构的说法，即正在进行的交易不是某人的欺骗换取你的金钱。
What's being trans, well, you believe that what's being transacted is just this act of courtesy between two people. And so there's both self-deception and deception, and I would argue that for much, much of the time, this is actually a good thing, because if you look at workplaces that are marked by rudeness where people simply say what's on their mind, these are not workplaces that are healthier workplaces or happier workplaces. In fact, we all are better off when we mind our manners, which is, of course, exactly what our mothers taught us many, many years ago.
正在进行的交易，嗯，你相信正在进行的交易只是两个人之间这种礼貌的行为。所以这里既有自我欺骗也有欺骗，而且我认为在很多很多时候，这实际上是一件好事，因为如果你看看那些以粗鲁为特征的工作场所，人们只是说出他们心里的想法，这些工作场所并不是更健康或更快乐的工作场所。事实上，当我们注意礼貌时，我们所有人都过得更好，这当然正是我们的母亲多年前教给我们的。
How can self-deception be good for our relationships? So this might be yet another concentric circle around the idea of self-deception. So when it comes to our intimate relationships, for example, Chris, imagine for a second that you could visit every single couple getting married in the United States this year. And you asked each couple on their wedding day, what are the odds you think you're going to get divorced? Now if they were purely rational creatures, logical creatures, if we expected people to give logical and rational answers to everything, people would look at the statistics and say
自我欺骗如何对我们的关系有益？所以这可能是关于自我欺骗概念的另一个同心圆。所以当谈到我们的亲密关系时，例如，克里斯，想象一下，如果你能拜访今年在美国结婚的每一对夫妇。你在他们的婚礼当天问每一对夫妇，你认为你们离婚的几率是多少？如果他们是纯粹理性的生物，逻辑生物，如果我们期望人们对一切都给出合乎逻辑和理性的回答，人们会看看统计数据并说
about half of all marriages and in divorce. There's no reason to think that I'm particularly special. And so there's about a 50-50 chance that I'm going to get divorced. Very few people on their wedding day are going to say that. I suspect that in many ways if they said that, they're probably not the kind of people who would get married. Because in some ways getting married involves the leap of faith that believes that you're in this relationship forever. And I think in many ways, the self-deception that we have about our partners, the beliefs that we have about our own feelings towards our partners, in many, many cases, this is functional.
大约一半的婚姻以离婚告终。没有理由认为我特别特别。所以我有大约50-50的机会离婚。在婚礼当天很少有人会这样说。我怀疑在很多方面，如果他们那样说，他们可能不是那种会结婚的人。因为在某种程度上，结婚涉及一种信念的飞跃，相信你们会永远在一起。而且我认为在很多方面，我们对自己伴侣的错觉，我们对自己对伴侣感受的信念，在很多很多情况下，这是有功能的。
If we actually saw our partners and friends and colleagues for exactly who they are all the time, we might judge them somewhat harshly. We might, in fact, decide in the risk benefit or the cost benefit analysis that the costs outweigh the benefits. And many of us might decide that, you know, we don't want to be in those relationships anymore. So allowing these relationships to function for long periods of time often requires some acts of self-deception, where you preferentially focus on the things that are good in the relationship
如果我们真的始终如一地看到我们的伴侣、朋友和同事的真实面目，我们可能会严厉地评判他们。我们甚至可能在风险收益或成本效益分析中决定成本超过了收益。我们许多人可能会决定，你知道，我们不想再维持那些关系了。因此，让这些关系长期运作通常需要一些自我欺骗的行为，你优先关注关系中好的方面，
and preferentially ignore the things that are bad in the relationship. This is especially true when it comes to friendships. I mean, imagine the last time you talked with a friend where you simply told your friend everything that was on your mind, good and bad. Most of us will recognize that when it comes to our friends, we preferentially focus on the good, say encouraging things, hopeful things, positive things, and we expect the same in return. Coming up after the break, I talk about one of the most useful delusions in my own life. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
并优先忽略关系中坏的方面。当谈到友谊时，这一点尤其正确。我的意思是，想象一下你上次和朋友交谈时，你只是告诉了你的朋友你心里想的一切，好的和坏的。我们大多数人会认识到，当谈到我们的朋友时，我们优先关注好的方面，说鼓励的话、充满希望的话、积极的话，我们也期望得到同样的回报。休息后回来，我将谈谈我自己生活中最有用的错觉之一。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week, we decided to share an interview I did with KERA's program Think. Here's the host of that show, Chris Boyd. We're about to hear one of the most popular recurring sketches of the comedy duo, Ki and Peel, from the Obama era. Jordan Peel plays it very straight as Obama, just saying the kinds of things the president might have said. Keegan Michael Key is his anger translator who is telling us all what Obama really thinks.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。本周，我们决定分享我与KERA节目《思考》的采访。这是该节目的主持人克里斯·博伊德。我们即将听到奥巴马时代喜剧二人组“基和皮尔”最受欢迎的循环小品之一。乔丹·皮尔非常严肃地扮演奥巴马，只是说总统可能说的那种话。基根-迈克尔·基是他的愤怒翻译，他告诉我们所有人奥巴马真正想的是什么。
First off, concerning the recent developments in the Middle Eastern region, I just want to reiterate our unflinching support for all people and their right to a democratic process. Hey, all y'all dictators out there, keep messing around and see what happens. Just see what happens. Watch! Shankar, do we all suppress our true feelings most of the time? So I think it's interesting when the people who don't suppress that true feelings most
首先，关于中东地区最近的事态发展，我只想重申我们对所有人及其享有民主进程权利的坚定支持。嘿，你们所有的独裁者，继续胡闹，看看会发生什么。等着瞧吧。看着！尚卡尔，我们大多数时候都在压抑自己的真实感受吗？所以我认为当那些不压抑真实感受的人
of the time, we don't actually have very positive things to say about them. I mean, it's interesting, most of us say that we greatly value truth tellers and we value the truth, but ask yourself what it's like to be around someone who simply tells you what's on their mind all the time. Most of us would actually find that to be an unpleasant experience. And so yes, I do think that in quote unquote civilized society, you know, most of us find ways to present what we say in a way that our audience is able to hear it.
大多数时候，我们实际上并没有对他们说非常积极的话。我的意思是，这很有趣，我们大多数人说我们非常重视真理讲述者，我们重视真理，但问问自己，和一个总是只说心里话的人在一起是什么感觉。我们大多数人实际上会发现那是一种不愉快的经历。所以是的，我确实认为在所谓的文明社会中，你知道，我们大多数人找到了以一种我们的听众能够听到的方式来表达我们所说内容的方法。
Now, certainly we expect that from people who are our presidents and managers and leaders, we expect people who are in positions of authority not simply to spout off on whatever thought they have in their head, but to actually consider carefully to weigh what it is that they're saying, to think about what the consequences of their words might be. Now, we don't think of those necessarily as delusions, but in some ways these are, in
现在，当然我们期望我们的总统、经理和领导人这样做，我们期望处于权威地位的人不仅要滔滔不绝地说出他们脑子里的任何想法，而且要仔细考虑，权衡他们所说的话，思考他们的话可能产生的后果。现在，我们不一定认为这些是错觉，但在某种程度上，这些是，在
some ways, perversions of the truth. We're changing the truth. We're shading the truth in order to present it in a way that people will be able to hear us properly. And as I said a second ago, organizations that don't do this, leaders that don't do this, who simply voice whatever's in their heads, these are not people who we applaud as truth tellers, these are people who often come across as rude or cruel. They're often people who do not get support in workplaces.
某种程度上，对真理的歪曲。我们正在改变真理。我们正在润色真理，以便以一种人们能够正确听到我们的方式来呈现它。正如我刚才所说，不这样做的工作场所，不这样做的领导者，只是说出他们脑子里有什么，这些不是我们鼓掌的真理讲述者，这些人往往显得粗鲁或残忍。他们往往是在工作场所得不到支持的人。
Years ago I called a friend and it sounded like I'd awakened her and I said, I'm so sorry that I wake you up and she just said, yes, which was true. And somehow I got my feelings hurt by that. And all of us, what's interesting here Chris is that your friend might have been too sleepy to have actually massed the truth and so she simply said what was on her mind. But in some ways all of us expect this of our friends. When you go to a friend and basically say, my life is terrible, you don't expect your friend to tell you, yes, your life is terrible because in fact,
几年前我给一个朋友打电话，听起来我吵醒了她，我说，我很抱歉吵醒了你，她只是说，是的，这是事实。不知何故，我的感情因此受到了伤害。而且我们所有人，克里斯，这里有趣的是，你的朋友可能太困了，无法掩盖真相，所以她只是说了她心里的想法。但在某种程度上，我们所有人都期望我们的朋友这样做。当你去找一个朋友，基本上说，我的生活太糟糕了，你不期望你的朋友告诉你，是的，你的生活太糟糕了，因为事实上，
you've made terrible life choices. You expect your friend to sort of say, I'm really sorry to hear that. How can I help? What can we do to make things better? If you have a friend who's going through a divorce, you know, you don't go and tell your friend, the truth is your life is probably over as you know it
你做出了糟糕的人生选择。你期望你的朋友说，听到这个我很难过。我能帮什么忙？我们能做些什么让事情变得更好？如果你有一个正在经历离婚的朋友，你知道，你不会去告诉你的朋友，事实是你的生活可能正如你所知的那样结束了，
and things are going to be miserable for you for a long time. No, you tell your friend, I'm sure everything's going to be okay and I'm sure you're going to get back on your feet pretty soon. We expect this of the people who are our friends. In fact, people who don't do this simply stop being our friends. So if we look at self-deception in service to optimism as an adaptive response, we need to consider why it's adaptive. It turns out evolutionary mechanisms care a lot less about us seeing the world accurately
而且在很长一段时间内你会很痛苦。不，你告诉你的朋友，我相信一切都会好起来的，我相信你很快就会重新站起来。我们期望我们的朋友这样做。事实上，不这样做的人就不再是我们的朋友了。所以如果我们把服务于乐观的自我欺骗看作一种适应性反应，我们需要考虑为什么它是适应性的。事实证明，进化机制对我们是否准确地看待世界并不那么关心，
than they care about us being alive and able to procreate. That's exactly right. I mean, when you think about it, you know, the average human lifespan, you know, it used to be 25 or 30 years, you know, a few centuries ago. But even now, even though it's extended quite a bit, let's say it's 75 or 80 years. In the larger story of the human presence on planet Earth, 75 or 80 years is almost nothing. Humans have been around for tens of thousands of years, and our individual lives are puny. Each of us is just one individual among 708 billion people on the planet. And this planet of ours is just one tiny planet in a solar system,
它们更关心我们是否活着并能够繁衍后代。这完全正确。我的意思是，当你想到它时，你知道，人类的平均寿命，你知道，几个世纪前是25或30岁。但即使现在，即使它延长了很多，假设是75或80岁。在地球上人类存在的宏大故事中，75或80岁几乎什么都不是。人类已经存在了数万年，我们个人的生命是微不足道的。我们每个人只是地球上70到80亿人中的一个。而我们这个星球只是太阳系中一颗微小的行星，
and the sun that we have in our solar system is one of millions of solar systems in our galaxy, and that galaxy is one of maybe two trillion galaxies in the known universe. And so our individual lives are actually very, very, very puny, almost entirely and easily forgotten and forgettable. Now this is not a useful attitude to be able to clearly see how insignificant we are, is not a useful attitude when it comes to waking up in the morning and putting on our clothes and getting on our Zoom calls and doing all the things we have to do.
而我们太阳系中的太阳是银河系中数百万个太阳系中的一个，而那个银河系可能是已知宇宙中大约两万亿个银河系中的一个。所以我们个人的生命实际上是非常、非常、非常微小的，几乎完全且容易被遗忘。现在，这并不是一种有用的态度，能够清楚地看到我们是多么微不足道，在早上起床、穿上衣服、参加Zoom会议和做我们必须做的所有事情时，这并不是一种有用的态度。
And so all over the world in every culture, people have come up with ways to make their lives more palatable, to give their lives a sense of purpose, to give their lives a sense of meaning. This is especially true, I think, when it comes to our relationship with our children. You know, when the relationships between parents and children, our relationships that are usually marked by great heaps of delusional thinking. I know that when my own daughter was born, I thought of her as being the most special child in the entire universe, you know, the most, the ultimate miracle beyond all miracles. And I think many parents experience this when a child is born to them. They think that this child has to be the most special child in the
所以世界各地，在每一种文化中，人们都想出了让生活变得更可口的方法，赋予生活一种目的感，赋予生活一种意义感。我认为，当谈到我们与孩子的关系时，这一点尤其正确。你知道，父母和孩子之间的关系，通常是充满大量错觉思维的关系。我知道当我自己的女儿出生时，我认为她是整个宇宙中最特别的孩子，你知道，超越所有奇迹的终极奇迹。而且我认为许多父母在孩子出生时都会有这种体验。他们认为这个孩子一定是整个宇宙历史上
history of the entire universe. Now, logically, that can't possibly be true. It can't possibly be true that millions of people can simultaneously think that their children are the most special children of all the other children out there. But this is a very useful delusion to have, because parenting turns out to be costly, time-consuming, difficult, frustrating, often irritating, and our delusional beliefs about our children buffer us against the challenges of parenting. They allow us in some ways to deal with the body blows that parenting often delivers to us. Here's another example of why it is in our evolutionary history.
最特别的孩子。现在，从逻辑上讲，这不可能正确。数以百万计的人不可能同时认为他们的孩子是所有其他孩子中最特别的孩子。但这是一种非常有用的错觉，因为育儿结果证明是昂贵的、耗时的、困难的、令人沮丧的、经常令人恼火的，而我们对孩子错觉般的信念缓冲了我们应对育儿挑战的压力。它们在某种程度上允许我们应对育儿经常带给我们的身体打击。这是为什么它在我们的进化史上存在的另一个例子。
Evolutionists thought fit in some ways to implant in our minds delusions, powerful delusions that our children are extraordinary and special. I've always thought that might play into the fact that we really fear kidnapping to an extent that is not at all borne out by the rates at which it happens. I would take nothing away from the tragedy that it does happen at all, but most children are really not at risk of this at any point in their lives. But we all think this kid is so perfect who wouldn't want this child? Yes, and I think many of us go overboard
进化论者认为，在某种程度上，在我们的头脑中植入错觉是合适的，强大的错觉认为我们的孩子是非凡的和特别的。我一直认为这可能与我们非常害怕绑架有关，这种程度完全没有被它发生的频率所证实。我一点也不会削弱它确实发生这一悲剧的事实，但大多数孩子在他们生命中的任何时候实际上都没有这种风险。但我们都认为这个孩子太完美了，谁会不想要这个孩子呢？是的，而且我认为我们许多人做得过火了
in order to protect our children, and this can sometimes harm our children, it can harm us and it can harm our children. In fact, there are examples down history of people's love for their children, not just leading them astray and leading their families astray, but leading entire nations astray. You can see how this delusional love can produce sometimes things that are problems.
为了保护我们的孩子，这有时会伤害我们的孩子，它会伤害我们，也会伤害我们的孩子。事实上，历史上有人们对孩子的爱不仅导致他们误入歧途，导致他们的家庭误入歧途，而且导致整个国家误入歧途的例子。你可以看到这种错觉般的爱有时会产生一些问题。
But the underlying reason that you have the delusional belief in the first place is that it performs a certain functional role. One of the central messages of my book is that when we think about delusions, we're often so focused and so intent on the content of the delusions, and we're often so upset by the content of the delusions, that we don't stop to ask the deeper psychological question, what purpose is it serving? What is the function of this delusion? Now understanding the purpose and the function of something doesn't mean that you have to
但你首先拥有这种错觉信念的根本原因是它发挥了某种功能性作用。我书中的核心信息之一是，当我们思考错觉时，我们往往如此专注于错觉的内容，并且往往对错觉的内容感到如此不安，以至于我们没有停下来问更深层的心理学问题，它在服务什么目的？这种错觉的功能是什么？现在理解某事的目的和功能并不意味着你必须
agree with it. You can still think that it's a delusion, you can still think that something is a dangerous delusion, but understanding it gives you tools and avenues to potentially dismantle dangerous delusions and potentially also to embrace the useful ones. That brings us perfectly to the question of placebo in medicine. They seem unethical and yet if patients improve, I mean, that's the ultimate goal, right? So this is a really, really tricky, thorny, ethical question, because I think a variety of studies find that people do respond to placebo and placebo sort of broadly define, not just sort of sugar
同意它。你仍然可以认为它是一种错觉，你仍然可以认为某事是一种危险的错觉，但理解它给了你工具和途径来潜在地拆除危险的错觉，并潜在地拥抱有用的错觉。这完美地引出了医学中安慰剂的问题。它们看起来不道德，但如果病人好转，我的意思是，那是最终目标，对吧？所以这是一个非常、非常棘手、棘手的伦理问题，因为我认为各种研究发现人们确实对安慰剂有反应，安慰剂被广泛定义，不仅仅是糖
pills, but the entire practice of going to see a doctor and visiting a mental medical facility and seeing people in these impressive gowns and all the hoopla that surrounds a medical facility are partly why as we get treated we improve that we believe that we're going to get helped and so in fact we are helped. Now the dilemma here is that medicine is known for a long time that the placebo effect works that the effect that doctors have a very powerful effect on their patients. The question is should you reach for that as a cure? In other words, instead of actually prescribing a treatment,
药丸，而是去看医生、访问医疗设施、看到穿着这些令人印象深刻的长袍的人以及围绕医疗设施的所有大张旗鼓的整个实践，都是我们得到治疗时好转的部分原因，我们相信我们会得到帮助，所以事实上我们得到了帮助。现在的困境是，医学界早就知道安慰剂效应有效，医生对他们的病人有非常强大的影响。问题是你应该把它作为一种治疗手段吗？换句话说，而不是真正开出一种治疗方法，
should the doctor take advantage of her power over the patient in order to help the patient feel better? There's not a simple answer to this question. I think it's a very complicated question, and question, and I think there are arguments to be made on both sides. Clearly, if doctors begin lying to patients all the time, just in order to elicit the placebo effect, you can see in all kinds of ways how this could damage doctor patient trust and potentially even reduce the power of the placebo effect going forward.
医生是否应该利用她对病人的权力来帮助病人感觉更好？这个问题没有简单的答案。我认为这是一个非常复杂的问题，而且我认为双方都有论点。显然，如果医生开始一直对病人撒谎，仅仅为了引出安慰剂效应，你可以看到这在各种方面如何损害医患信任，并可能甚至降低未来安慰剂效应的力量。
But you can also see that doctors who merely tell us when we go and see a doctor, here's what the last three peer reviewed studies said that I have read. Here's what I think we should do. Here's a medication, go home and let's see what doctor. You know, here's what the last three peer reviewed studies said that I've read. Here's what I think we should do. Here's a medication, go home and let's see what happens and let's see if your results fall in line with the clinical trials. This is not sort of what we often want to hear when we go to a doctor because part of why we go to a doctor or a physician or we turn to anyone for help when we're suffering from an illness is we're turning to another human being. We're basically saying, I'm frightened, I'm lonely, I'm afraid, help me. Reach out your hand to me.
但你也可以看到，当我们去看医生时，医生只是告诉我们，这是我读过的最后三项同行评审研究的结果。这是我认为我们应该做的。这是一种药物，回家看看医生。你知道，这是我读过的最后三项同行评审研究的结果。这是我认为我们应该做的。这是一种药物，回家看看会发生什么，看看你的结果是否符合临床试验。当我们去看医生或医师，或者当我们遭受疾病折磨时向任何人寻求帮助时，这并不是我们通常想听到的，因为我们去看医生或医师的部分原因是我们正在向另一个人求助。我们基本上是在说，我很害怕，我很孤独，我很恐惧，帮帮我。向我伸出你的手。
And this is why, in medical schools all over the world, increasing emphasis is being paid on what happens at the patient bedside. The relationship between doctor and patient is not incidental to the outcomes of medicine. It's essential to the outcomes of medicine, it's essential to the outcomes of medicine. How might something like the placebo effect influence how well our cars work for us? Yes, the placebo effect, of course, is based on the idea that if you believe that your doctor is going to do well and you've gone to a very good doctor and the doctor is giving you the latest medicine, you're going to get better. If that's sort of the premise of the placebo effect that the rituals and practices around the practice of medicine are
这就是为什么在世界各地的医学院中，越来越重视病人床边发生的事情。医生和病人之间的关系对于医学的结果并非偶然。它对于医学的结果至关重要，它对于医学的结果至关重要。像安慰剂效应这样的东西如何影响我们的汽车为我们工作的效果？是的，安慰剂效应当然是基于这样一种想法，即如果你相信你的医生会做得很好，而且你去看了一位非常好的医生，医生给你开了最新的药物，你会好起来的。如果这就是安慰剂效应的前提，即围绕医学实践的仪式和做法是
partly what make us better. The question arises, can this actually affect us in all kinds of other ways? In other words, when we go to a fancy restaurant, for example, are we partly influenced by how fancy the restaurant is as we judge whether the meal is tasty or not. Researchers have conducted studies on this. When you give people wine to drink and you have a bottle of wine that costs $10, but you pour the wine into a bottle that is marked at and priced at $90. In other words, you're drinking $10 wine, but it's poured out of a $90 bottle. People will sometimes perceive that wine as being superior to the original $10 wine. In other words, knowing that this is a $90 wine or believing it's a $90 wine tells
我们好转的部分原因。问题就出现了，这实际上能以各种其他方式影响我们吗？换句话说，当我们去一家高档餐厅时，例如，我们在判断这顿饭是否美味时，是否部分受到餐厅有多高档的影响。研究人员对此进行了研究。当你给人们喝葡萄酒，你有一瓶价值10美元的葡萄酒，但你把葡萄酒倒入一个标价为90美元的瓶子里。换句话说，你喝的是10美元的葡萄酒，但它是从90美元的瓶子里倒出来的。人们有时会认为那种葡萄酒比原来的10美元葡萄酒更优越。换句话说，知道这是90美元的葡萄酒或相信它是90美元的葡萄酒告诉
you that it's a better wine than wine that's $10, but it's not just a logical inference you're making. You're actually subjectively experiencing the wine is better. Maybe you take more time to savor it because you're spending so much money on your wine. It turns out the same thing affects a variety of other consumer and customer products. There have been instances, for example, of different cars that have been manufactured on the very same manufacturing plant, but they are marketed and branded by companies and sold on the different brand names, sometimes for very different prices, with one of them being sold for thousands of dollars more than the other. And some studies have found that the more expensive cars with the better brand names
你认为它比10美元的酒更好，但这不仅仅是你做出的逻辑推断。你实际上是在主观地体验到这瓶酒更好。也许你花了更多时间去品味它，因为你在酒上花了很多钱。事实证明，同样的事情也影响着各种其他消费品和客户产品。例如，曾有案例显示，不同的汽车在同一家制造厂生产，但由不同的公司进行营销和品牌推广，并以不同的品牌名称出售，有时价格差异巨大，其中一款的售价比另一款高出数千美元。一些研究发现，那些拥有更好品牌名称的昂贵汽车
in fact perform better over their lifetimes, which is really mysterious because these are the same cars as the less expensive cars that are sold under the less fancy brand name. And the reason that has been advanced is that the reason this happens is that when you spend more money to buy a more expensive car, when you buy a brand-name car with a very fancy title or a fancy name, you're going to take better care of that car. You're going to drive it more carefully. Maybe you park it more carefully. Maybe you find sheltering or a garage where you can park your car because you don't want it to be affected by the elements.
实际上在它们的使用寿命内表现更好，这真的很神秘，因为这些车与那些以不太高档的品牌名称出售的廉价汽车是完全相同的。提出的理由是，这种情况之所以发生，是因为当你花更多的钱去买一辆更昂贵的车时，当你买一辆带有非常华丽头衔或华丽名称的品牌车时，你会更爱护那辆车。你会更小心地驾驶它。也许你会更小心地停车。也许你会为你的车找到遮蔽处或车库，因为你不希望它受到风吹雨打。
You change the oil more regularly. You maintain the car much better. Over the course of several years, your beliefs, your actions on the car in some ways mean that the car is actually going to last longer. So two identical cars that are manufactured in exactly the same way, but one of them in some ways has more of the placebo effect attached to it. The car with the better placebo effect might in fact turn out to be the more reliable car. And in some ways this is very much like what we said a second ago in terms of relationships.
你会更定期地更换机油。你会更好地保养这辆车。在几年时间里，你的信念、你对汽车采取的行动在某种程度上意味着这辆车实际上会使用得更久。所以两辆以完全相同方式制造的完全相同的汽车，但其中一辆在某种程度上附带了更多的安慰剂效应。拥有更好安慰剂效应的汽车实际上可能最终成为更可靠的汽车。在某些方面，这非常类似于我们刚才所说的关于人际关系的内容。
The fact that I believe that I'm in a good relationship, that I have a delusional belief about the relationship, that might be one of the ingredients that makes my relationship good. I think we usually imagine that we're just looking at the world and reacting to the world. The premise of my book is that the ways we respond to the world shape how we interact with the world and then shape the outcomes we see in the world. Okay, what is naive realism? And how does that play into the ways we judge the actions and perceptions of other people? Naive realism is a phenomenon that affects all of us, Chris,
我相信我处于一段良好的关系中，我对这段关系有一种错觉，这可能就是使我的关系变得良好的因素之一。我认为我们通常想象我们只是在观察世界并对世界做出反应。我这本书的前提是，我们对世界做出反应的方式塑造了我们与世界互动的方式，进而塑造了我们在世界上看到的结果。好的，什么是朴素现实主义？它如何影响我们判断他人行为和感知的方式？朴素现实主义是一种影响我们所有人的现象，克里斯，
when we look out at other people. We imagine that we can sort of put ourselves in their shoes and very quickly ask, what would we do in that situation? So in other words, when I look at your actions, I believe I have a very clear understanding of why it is that you're doing what it is you're doing. We'd fail to see all the ways in some ways in which we ourselves are constrained by our own subjectivity, our own limits of being creatures that are embodied inside a single mind. As a result of this, we often fail to exercise the empathy that we might
当我们审视他人时。我们想象自己可以设身处地地为他们着想，并很快问自己，如果是我，在那种情况下会怎么做？换句话说，当我审视你的行为时，我相信我对你为什么这样做有着非常清晰的理解。我们未能看到我们在某些方面受到自身主观性的限制，受到我们作为被禁锢在单一思想中的生物的局限性的限制。因此，我们常常无法发挥我们本可以
otherwise exercise. So when we see people pursue delusional beliefs or engage in self-deception, it's easy to sit in judgment of those people, because when you look at them from the outside, through the lens of naiv realism, you tell yourself, I would never do that stupid thing if I was in their shoes. You imagine that you're outside of that experience. Now of course, this goes back to the idea we talked about, there being no atheists in the foxhole. When you're outside the foxhole, it's easy to imagine that people who turn to beliefs
发挥的同理心。所以，当我们看到人们追求错觉或进行自我欺骗时，很容易去评判这些人，因为当你从外部通过朴素现实主义的视角审视他们时，你会告诉自己，如果我处在他们的位置，我绝不会做那种蠢事。你想象自己置身于那种体验之外。当然，这回到了我们谈到的那个观点，即战壕里没有无神论者。当你置身于战壕之外时，很容易想象那些转向
about supernatural powers are being foolish. Because you imagine I am too rational, I am too logical, my mind works so much better than these simpletons, I would never do that. And naive realism convinces us that we would not fall prey to the same biases. Of course many of us realize that when we ourselves are in positions of great vulnerability, we turn to such beliefs ourselves. I should just mention one personal story here, because something occurred something happened to me a few months ago that I think it's very germane to this.
超自然力量信仰的人是愚蠢的。因为你想象我太理性了，我太有逻辑了，我的思维比这些傻瓜好得多，我绝不会那样做。而朴素现实主义让我们相信，我们不会成为同样偏见的受害者。当然，我们许多人意识到，当我们自己处于极度脆弱的境地时，我们自己也会转向这样的信仰。我应该在这里提一个个人故事，因为几个月前发生在我身上的一件事，我认为与此非常相关。
I was traveling a few hours from my home in Washington, DC. And I suffered a retina detachment. I suffered an impact right below my eye. And over the course of the next 24 hours, the retina, which is the film that allows you to see, you know, it's essentially the photographic film behind your eye that allows you to see, the retina started coming off its hinges.
当时我正从华盛顿特区的家中出发去旅行几个小时。我的视网膜脱落了。我的眼睛下方受到了一次撞击。在接下来的24小时里，视网膜，也就是让你能够看见东西的那层膜，你知道，它本质上是你眼睛后面让你能够看见东西的感光胶片，视网膜开始脱落了。
And at a certain point, if it detaches completely, you will lose sight in the eye altogether. And I have a family history of retinal problems, so I knew what was happening, and I could see, in some ways, my vision disappearing literally before my eyes. I was very far from home. I didn't know how to find a doctor. I was really frightened. When I finally managed to find an eye surgeon,
在某个时刻，如果它完全脱落，你将彻底失去视力。我有视网膜问题的家族史，所以我知道发生了什么，我可以看到，在某种程度上，我的视力确实在我的眼前消失了。我离家很远。我不知道怎么找医生。我真的很害怕。当我最终设法找到一位眼科医生时，
he very kindly opened his practice for me at 9 o'clock on a Tuesday night. He diagnosed me with a retina Detachment and said, you know, we need to wheel you in to get surgery within the next several minutes. You're gonna lose your eye otherwise. At that point, I didn't have time to weigh the pros and cons. I didn't have time to look up reviews and see if this person was a good doctor or a bad doctor. And I did what all of us do in positions of great vulnerability, I put all my faith and trust in this doctor. Now as it turned out, he was a brilliant surgeon and he ended up saving my eye for which I'm profoundly grateful.
他在周二晚上9点非常友善地为我开了诊所。他诊断我视网膜脱落，并说，你知道，我们需要在接下来的几分钟内把你推进去进行手术。否则你会失去你的眼睛。在那一刻，我没有时间权衡利弊。我没有时间去查阅评论，看看这个人是好医生还是坏医生。我做了我们所有人在极度脆弱时都会做的事情，我把我所有的信念和信任都寄托在这位医生身上。事实证明，他是一位出色的外科医生，他最终保住了我的眼睛，对此我深表感激。
But imagine for a second that he had not been a brilliant doctor. Let's imagine that he had been a shalatin. Would it have been any less likely for me to put my faith in him? And I would argue the answer is no, because my faith did not arise because of what he did, my faith arose because of what I was going through. I was going through a period of great vulnerability, a period of great fear, trusting him made me feel better, which is why I reached out to him. Expand this in all kinds of different ways and you can see why people sometimes gravitate to beliefs that are false, to demagogues and false prophets, it's not so much because of the demagogues and false prophets,
但试想一下，如果他不是一位出色的医生。让我们想象他是一个江湖骗子。我对他寄予厚望的可能性会降低吗？我认为答案是否定的，因为我的信念不是因为他做了什么而产生的，我的信念是因为我正在经历的事情而产生的。我正在经历一段极度脆弱、极度恐惧的时期，信任他让我感觉更好，这就是我向他求助的原因。将此以各种不同的方式扩展，你就能明白为什么人们有时会被错误的信仰、煽动者和假先知所吸引，这与其说是为了煽动者和假先知，
it's because of their own inner vulnerabilities. My guest journalist, Shankar Vidantham, is host of the Hidden Brain Podcast. We're talking about his latest book, Useful Delusions, The Power and Paradox of the Self-Decieving Brain. useful delusions, the power and paradox of the self-deceiving brain. Coming up, why it's so hard for us to let go of our self-deceptions. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week we are bringing you an interview I did with Chris Boyd for KERA's program Think.
不如说是为了他们自己内心的脆弱。我的嘉宾记者，尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，是《隐藏的大脑》播客的主持人。我们正在谈论他的最新著作《有用的错觉：自我欺骗大脑的力量与悖论》。《有用的错觉：自我欺骗大脑的力量与悖论》。接下来，为什么我们如此难以放下我们的自我欺骗。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。本周我们为你带来我为KERA的节目《思考》所做的采访。
It's centered around the things I learned while researching my latest book, Useful Delusions. Our conversation led us to a movie filled with rich psychological insights the world I created for you. I'm seeing my health. I'm seeing deceit. But in my world, you have nothing to fear. All right, Shankar, in that scene, I mean, we've watched the whole movie and realized lots of people actively contributed to the deception that Truman, Jim
它围绕着我在研究我的最新著作《有用的错觉》时学到的东西。我们的谈话引导我们进入了一部充满丰富心理洞察力的电影《楚门的世界》。我看到了我的健康。我看到了欺骗。但在我的世界里，你没有什么可害怕的。好的，尚卡尔，在那个场景中，我的意思是，我们看完了整部电影，意识到很多人积极地促成了楚门——吉姆·凯瑞饰演的角色——所陷入的欺骗。
Carrey's character, fell for. And we feel like though, maybe he should have suspected earlier, except that would have forced him to give up on believing in a lot of good things in his life, right? That's right. So the premise of the Truman show is that Truman is a part of a reality show, except he's the only one in the reality show who doesn't realize he's part of a reality show, except he's the only one in the reality show who doesn't realize he's part of a reality show. So his wife, his best friend, and his colleagues, and co-workers, and everyone who lives in
我们觉得，也许他应该早点怀疑，除非那会迫使他放弃相信生活中很多美好的事物，对吧？没错。所以《楚门的世界》的前提是楚门是一个真人秀节目的一部分，只是他是真人秀节目中唯一一个没有意识到自己是真人秀节目一部分的人，只是他是真人秀节目中唯一一个没有意识到自己是真人秀节目一部分的人。所以他的妻子、他最好的朋友、他的同事、他的工作伙伴，以及所有住在他
his town, they're all actors, and he's the only one who doesn't understand or know that he is part of this reality show. What makes the deception very difficult to pierce is that in order to pierce the deception, Truman not only has to see through the deception, but he has to give up his emotional relationships with all the people in his life. He has to recognize that the wife he loves is in fact not, or somebody who he should love, that his best friend is not his best friend, that his co-workers and colleagues and neighbors are in fact actors. And this is very painful and true men in some ways is a wonderful,
镇上的人，他们都是演员，而他是唯一一个不理解或不知道自己是这个真人秀节目一部分的人。这种欺骗之所以很难被识破，是因为为了识破这种欺骗，楚门不仅要看穿这种欺骗，他还必须放弃他生活中所有人的情感关系。他必须认识到他所爱的妻子实际上并不是，或者不是他应该爱的人，他最好的朋友不是他最好的朋友，他的同事和邻居实际上是演员。这非常痛苦，而《楚门的世界》在某些方面是一个美妙的，
the true men show in some ways is a wonderful account for why it is that even when deceptions are unmasked, many of us sometimes are unwilling to let them go. The reason is not because we are foolish, it's not because we are stupid or that we're idiots, it's because that those beliefs, those delusions, those self-deceptions are now tied up with things that have become very emotionally important to us. And to challenge those self-deceptions means also challenging the relationships that have become vitally important to us. Now, in the little clip that you played that Chris, I would argue that the creator of the Truman show was in fact being not just deceptive, but unethical
《楚门的世界》在某些方面是一个美妙的解释，说明了为什么即使在欺骗被揭穿时，我们许多人有时也不愿放手。原因不是因为我们愚蠢，不是因为我们笨或者我们是白痴，而是因为那些信念、那些错觉、那些自我欺骗现在与对我们情感上非常重要的事情联系在一起了。挑战这些自我欺骗也意味着挑战那些对我们至关重要的关系。现在，在你播放的那个小片段中，克里斯，我会说《楚门的世界》的创作者实际上不仅是在欺骗，而且是不道德的，
in sort of the argument that he was making to Truman. I am not suggesting that we should deceive one another really nilly and say that it's a good thing that we're deceiving one another. That's not at all the point of the book. But I am saying that in some ways, if in some way self-deception is truly intended for the benefit of the person who you are intending to deceive or for your own good, there's an argument to truly intended for the benefit of the person whom you are intending to deceive or for your own good, there's an argument to be made for it. So the doctor who basically withholds
在他向楚门提出的论点中。我并不是建议我们应该随意地互相欺骗，并说我们互相欺骗是一件好事。这根本不是这本书的重点。但我确实在说，在某种程度上，如果自我欺骗确实是为了你打算欺骗的人的利益，或者是为了你自己的利益，那么这就有理由去支持它。所以那位医生基本上对绝症患者隐瞒了
from the terminal patient, the fact that she is gonna die in two weeks time and basically says, you know, things look pretty grim, but let's see how it goes. I would argue that that doctor is doing the humane thing. The doctor is not doing the unethical thing. Now, other people might disagree and say, even there, the doctor's obligation is just to tell the truth,
她将在两周内死亡的事实，并基本上说，你知道，情况看起来很严峻，但让我们看看会怎样。我认为那位医生做的是人道的事情。医生并没有做不道德的事情。现在，其他人可能会不同意，并说，即使在那里，医生的义务也只是说出真相，
you know, the brutal truth. But certainly it is the case that when the doctor deceives the patient in order for the doctor to gain, there is no question that that is unethical. If the doctor lies to the patient and says, I think you're going to live for another two years, so let's enter into a business venture together where you're forking over a bunch of money to me. That's not deception or self-deception with the patience good in mind. That's sort of straightforward, that's being a con man,
你知道，残酷的真相。但可以肯定的是，当医生为了自己的利益而欺骗病人时，毫无疑问这是不道德的。如果医生对病人撒谎说，我认为你还能再活两年，所以让我们一起进行一项商业投资，你把一大笔钱交给我。那不是为了病人的利益而进行的欺骗或自我欺骗。那是一种直接的，那是骗子的行为，
that's being a scumbag. That's not the kind of deception that I'm talking about in the book at all in terms of deception that we might want to honor or potentially protect. Yeah, I have been thinking about the ways that our personal self-deception could potentially hurt other people, but it also our tendency for self-deception explains that as a white person who really wants to live my life in anti-racist ways, I've been convinced by the research into unconscious bias that says, you know, I may have thoughts that don't reflect my values, but they still exist within me. On the other hand, it's always so hard to to think of yourself as belonging to this system that is abusive and really hurts people of color in this country. Can you talk about why it's so hard for us? Does self-deception play into our denial of racism?
那是人渣的行为。那根本不是我在书中谈论的那种我们可能想要尊重或潜在保护的欺骗。是的，我一直在思考我们的个人自我欺骗可能伤害他人的方式，但我们对自我欺骗的倾向也解释了这一点，作为一个真正想以反种族主义方式生活的白人，我被关于无意识偏见的研究说服了，这些研究说，你知道，我可能有一些不反映我价值观的想法，但它们仍然存在于我内心。另一方面，认为自己属于这个虐待并真正伤害这个国家有色人种的系统总是很难。你能谈谈为什么这对我们来说这么难吗？自我欺骗是否在我们对种族主义的否认中起作用？
Absolutely. It plays into our denial of all manners of different kinds of biases and prejudice. There's no question about it. And the reason is almost straightforward. The reason is it's painful to think of ourselves as being people who are biased, as people who have racial bias, or the thing that we have sexist people is painful or homophobic people. It's painful to think of ourselves that way. And it's also easy to imagine that we're outside of that world when in fact we're not. And in many ways, this particular idea is a central idea of my first book, The Hidden Brain. It's all about the power of the unconscious mind and the role of unconscious bias in shaping our daily lives.
绝对起作用。它在我们对各种偏见和歧视的否认中都起作用。毫无疑问。原因几乎是直接的。原因是，认为自己是一个有偏见的人，是一个有种族偏见的人，或者我们有性别歧视的人，或者恐同的人，这很痛苦。那样看待自己很痛苦。而且很容易想象我们置身于那个世界之外，而实际上我们并没有。在许多方面，这个特定的观点是我第一本书《隐藏的大脑》的核心观点。它完全是关于潜意识的力量以及潜意识偏见在塑造我们日常生活中的作用。
Many years ago, the psychologist Leon Festinger infiltrated a group that believed the world was gonna come to an end on a certain day, and Festinger infiltrated the group because he wanted to see what happened when the world did not come to an end, and he fully expected that people would tell themselves, okay, I was wrong, I made a mistake, this was a delusional belief and they would let it go. But that emphatically is not what happened. When the day of judgment came and the world did not come to an end,
多年前，心理学家利昂·费斯廷格潜入了一个相信世界将在某一天终结的团体，费斯廷格潜入该团体是因为他想看看当世界没有终结时会发生什么，他完全预期人们会告诉自己，好吧，我错了，我犯了一个错误，这是一个错误的信念，他们会放手。但事实并非如此。当审判日到来而世界没有终结时，
the people in this group came up with rationalizations of why it was the world did not end. And in fact, they said, the various steps that we took because we anticipated the world was going to end, these are the steps that headed off the world from actually ending. You know, writ large, the same phenomenon affects large groups of people. It allows people to keep their heads stuck in the sand, to close their eyes to reality.
这个团体中的人们想出了为什么世界没有终结的合理化解释。事实上，他们说，我们因为预见到世界将要终结而采取的各种步骤，正是这些步骤阻止了世界真正终结。你知道，推而广之，同样的现象影响着大群体的人。它让人们把头埋在沙子里，对现实视而不见。
You know, it allows political delusions to surface in all kinds of ways. And the reason, the underlying reason in all these cases is the same, sometimes seeing the truth can be deeply painful. My book is not at all making the argument that all self-deceptions are good. In many cases, it's really the wise and important and valuable thing to do to open our eyes and to see the role that we're playing and the ways in which we might harm and hurt one another, but it's also really important, I think, when we look at the delusions in self-deceptions of other people to look at them with compassion, to look at them with empathy, I would argue that in many ways we're going to be more effective dismantling dangerous delusions when we bring empathy and sympathy and compassion to bear rather than judgment.
你知道，它让政治错觉以各种方式浮出水面。而在所有这些案例中，根本原因都是一样的，有时看到真相会非常痛苦。我的书根本不是在争论所有的自我欺骗都是好的。在许多情况下，睁开眼睛，看到我们所扮演的角色以及我们可能伤害彼此的方式，确实是明智、重要和有价值的事情，但我也认为，当我们审视他人的错觉和自我欺骗时，用同情心去看待他们，用同理心去看待他们，这也非常重要。我认为在许多方面，当我们带着同理心、同情心和怜悯心而不是评判时，我们将更有效地瓦解危险的错觉。
All right, I want to go to the phones. Let's speak with Danny in Fort Worth, Texas. Hi, Danny. Hi, thanks for taking my call. I was really interested in hearing, you know, I've heard the analogy about wine and an extensive wine tasting better, but the car one stood out to me. And it made me curious if being of a higher socioeconomic class kind of enables self-deception in a way that might not be, you know, that might be a privilege over folks
好的，我想接听电话。让我们和德克萨斯州沃斯堡的丹尼谈谈。你好，丹尼。你好，谢谢你接我的电话。我真的很有兴趣听到，你知道，我听过关于酒和昂贵的酒品尝起来更好的类比，但汽车那个例子对我来说很突出。这让我很好奇，处于更高的社会经济阶层是否以一种可能不是，你知道，可能是一种特权的方式使自我欺骗成为可能，而对于那些
who are financially struggling who don't have the same resources to engage in that same sort of self-deception. Thanks for calling. Yeah, I think that's a really interesting question, Danny. I would argue not so much that I think self-deceptions are more likely or less likely. I would just say the form that those self-deceptions take are likely to be different. And again, if you think about self-deception as being fundamentally designed to be functional, self-deceptions are filling gaps in our lives, things that we think are missing, we're filling it in with self-deception. So somebody,
经济拮据、没有同样资源去进行那种自我欺骗的人来说，情况可能并非如此。谢谢你的来电。是的，我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，丹尼。我认为与其说我认为自我欺骗更有可能或更不可能发生，不如说我认为自我欺骗的形式可能会有所不同。同样，如果你认为自我欺骗从根本上说是为了发挥功能而设计的，自我欺骗是在填补我们生活中的空白，我们认为缺失的东西，我们用自我欺骗来填补它。所以某人，
for example, who's very poor, might come up with self-deceptions that reassure them that maybe the future is not going to be so grim, or they come up with beliefs that give them cause for hope and optimism, because their present lives are difficult, their present circumstances are so challenging. Somebody who's well off might not have concerns about their economic security the next week, but they may have concerns about how they're perceived, about how other people might perceive them, and their self-deceptions might indeed take the form of being blind to the ways that they might cause harm to others. So, you know, you could argue, as opposed to maybe some of these self-deceptions have more impact and certainly more impact on other people, that's entirely possible.
例如，非常贫穷的人，可能会想出一些自我欺骗，让他们确信未来可能不会那么严峻，或者他们想出一些给他们带来希望和乐观的信念，因为他们现在的生活很困难，他们现在的处境非常具有挑战性。富裕的人可能不会担心下周的经济保障，但他们可能会担心自己如何被感知，担心其他人如何看待他们，而他们的自我欺骗确实可能表现为对他们可能伤害他人的方式视而不见。所以，你知道，你可以争辩说，相对于可能其中一些自我欺骗有更大的影响，当然对他人有更大的影响，这是完全可能的。
But I'm more inclined to think of these self-deceptions as being functional things that brains are designed to do. Regardless of where you put us, regardless of our circumstances, there are things that all of us find difficult accountants, and those are precisely the areas where self-deception is likely to flourish. You acknowledge here that religious faith can play a really positive role in people's lives, but there may still be some aspects of self-deception in that. What was the miracle of the Sun? So the miracle of the Sun, like many other religious miracles, involved large numbers of people believing that they had seen a supernatural event take place. This event took place about a hundred years ago. What's striking about this is that this was not a couple of people who had this experience.
但我更倾向于认为这些自我欺骗是大脑被设计用来做的功能性事情。无论你把我们放在哪里，无论我们的处境如何，都有一些我们所有人都觉得困难的事情，而这些正是自我欺骗最容易滋生的地方。你在这里承认宗教信仰可以在人们的生活中发挥非常积极的作用，但其中可能仍然存在一些自我欺骗。什么是太阳神迹？所以太阳神迹，像许多其他宗教神迹一样，涉及大量的人相信他们看到了超自然事件的发生。这个事件发生在大约一百年前。令人震惊的是，这并不是几个人有了这种体验。
There were many, many, a large number of people who collectively witnessed something that they thought was the hand of the supernatural, the hand of God at play. But of course, when you look a little bit deeper, what you find is that this happened at a time when large numbers of people arrived at a place believing that they were going to see a miracle. The miracle had been foretold at an earlier time. And so when they showed up, many people had come great distances, many, many miles to see something remarkable.
有很多人，大量的人集体目睹了他们认为是超自然力量、上帝之手在起作用的事情。但当然，当你深入一点看时，你会发现这发生在一个很多人到达一个地方相信他们会看到神迹的时候。神迹在更早的时候就已经预言了。所以当他们出现时，许多人已经走了很远的距离，很多很多英里来看一些非凡的事情。
And so they were predisposed in some ways to see something remarkable. We see this at all kinds of different ways in all over the world right now, in different settings of people believing that they can see certain things. You know, after the 9-11 attacks, for example, there was a memorial that was held where two very bright blue lights were shown into the sky, in some ways as a, you know, as a stand-in for the twin towers that came down. And when those lights were shining in the sky, many people believed that at the peak of the lights, they could see what looked like an angel or a cross.
所以他们在某种程度上倾向于看到一些非凡的事情。我们现在在世界各地的各种不同方式中都看到了这一点，在人们相信他们能看到某些事情的不同环境中。你知道，在9-11袭击之后，例如，举行了一个纪念活动，两道非常明亮的蓝光射向天空，在某种程度上作为倒塌的双子塔的替代品。当那些光在天空中闪耀时，许多人相信在光的顶端，他们可以看到看起来像天使或十字架的东西。
And of course, it might have been an optical illusion, but the reason that we see this optical illusion is because there is an underlying grief, there's an underlying vulnerability that we're trying to find a way to respond to. And again, if you're outside of that grief, if you don't share in that grief, it's easy to look down at people who are able to see those things, who are able to see, to sort of come up with these self-deceptions. When you're in these things, when you've experienced the suffering and the setback yourself, you realize how easy it is to turn to such beliefs. We've mostly talked this hour, Shankar, about self-deceptions that affect us on an individual level.
当然，这可能是一种视错觉，但我们看到这种视错觉的原因是因为存在一种潜在的悲伤，存在一种我们试图找到应对方法的潜在脆弱性。同样，如果你置身于那种悲伤之外，如果你不分担那种悲伤，很容易看不起那些能够看到这些东西的人，那些能够看到，能够想出这些自我欺骗的人。当你身处这些事情之中，当你自己经历过痛苦和挫折时，你就会意识到转向这样的信仰是多么容易。这一小时我们主要谈论的是影响我们个人层面的自我欺骗，尚卡尔。
How does the process work when entire groups of people dilute themselves into believing something that's not accurate? So like all self-deceptions and delusions, you know, these can happen not just at the individual level or the interpersonal level but they can happen at the level of groups, tribes, even nations and countries. And like all of these, the other self-deceptions and delusions we've talked about, there are clearly ways in which these delusions can cause great harm, but there are also ways in which these delusions can cause great good. Let me give you a simplest example. You know, it's hard for most of us to think about nations as delusions. But of course, nations are human inventions.
当整个群体的人欺骗自己去相信一些不准确的事情时，这个过程是如何运作的？所以像所有的自我欺骗和错觉一样，你知道，这些不仅可以发生在个人层面或人际层面，它们还可以发生在群体、部落，甚至国家和国家的层面。像所有这些我们谈论过的其他自我欺骗和错觉一样，显然这些错觉在某些方面会造成巨大的伤害，但它们在某些方面也会造成巨大的好处。让我给你举一个最简单的例子。你知道，我们大多数人很难把国家看作是错觉。但当然，国家是人类的发明。
Human beings have come up with a concept of nations and says, here's where the United States ends and here's where Canada begins or here's where the United States ends and here's where Mexico begins. These are human inventions, human conventions agreed upon by the people who live within a country and by the people who live outside of that country. Now, you can think of, if you think about the nation as a delusion in the way that I'm describing the word delusion, not as a negative, but just as something that was invented by the human mind, you can see all kinds of good things that nations do. When you have a natural disaster in one state, for example, people in another state will step forward to help. Someone in Maryland may say that when there's a natural disaster in Texas, I feel obliged
人类想出了国家的概念，并说，这是美国结束的地方，这是加拿大开始的地方，或者这是美国结束的地方，这是墨西哥开始的地方。这些是人类的发明，是生活在一个国家内的人和生活在那个国家外的人所同意的人类公约。现在，你可以认为，如果你以我描述错觉这个词的方式来思考国家作为一种错觉，不是作为一种负面，而只是作为人类大脑发明的东西，你可以看到国家所做的各种好事。例如，当一个州发生自然灾害时，另一个州的人会站出来提供帮助。马里兰州的人可能会说，当德克萨斯州发生自然灾害时，我感到有义务
to help because we're all part of the same big country. You know, the resources, if one part of the country is doing well, we might send resources from another part of the country that's doing better to help the part of the country that's not doing so well. So in other words, we stand together, we help one another, we lift one another up in difficult times. These are all the ways in which nations can be very, very function and very, very powerful. Now, you can easily ask the question, can these delusions spill over into harm? And you only have to look at the very brief history of the 20th century to see all the ways in which nationalism can cause immense harm, including, and up to the point of genocide,
去帮助，因为我们都是同一个大国家的一部分。你知道，资源，如果国家的一部分做得很好，我们可能会从做得更好的国家另一部分派遣资源来帮助做得不太好的那部分。所以换句话说，我们站在一起，我们互相帮助，我们在困难时期互相扶持。这些都是国家可以非常、非常实用且非常、非常强大的方式。现在，你可以很容易地问这个问题，这些错觉会蔓延到伤害吗？你只需要看看20世纪非常简短的历史，就能看到民族主义可以造成巨大伤害的所有方式，包括，直到种族灭绝的程度，
of groups believing so deeply, so fervently, in the delusions that they have come up with, that they're willing to fight and kill and destroy large numbers of other people You know the service of those delusions, you know I sometimes wonder you know, you know, this is The proverbial Anthropologists that comes to us from another planet. Let's say you had a the an anthropologist come to us from another galaxy You know and travels across these vast realms of space to come to this tiny little planet. And they would find something astonishing. They would find that this one species, human being, which is one species among 8 million
群体如此深刻、如此热切地相信他们想出的错觉，以至于他们愿意为了服务于这些错觉而战斗、杀戮和摧毁大量其他人。你知道，我有时会想，你知道，这是来自另一个星球的谚语中的人类学家。假设你有一个来自另一个星系的类人猿来到我们这里。你知道，穿越这些广阔的空间领域来到这个微小的星球。他们会发现一些令人震惊的事情。他们会发现这个物种，人类，是800万种物种中的一种
species on the planet, somehow believes that we have the right to divide up this planet into 190 different territories. And we believe in these territories so deeply that we're willing to destroy one another over the integrity of these territories, that we've armed ourselves with nuclear weapons, and we're willing to destroy the entire planet because we believe so powerfully in the reality of these inventions. Surely this anthropologist from another galaxy would think of this as being a delusion. Many of us, of course, don't because when you're inside a delusion, that's usually the hardest place to recognize that you're experiencing a delusion. Briefly, if we know someone else is deceiving themselves, but in a
星球上的物种，竟然相信我们有权把这个星球划分成190个不同的领土。我们如此深刻地相信这些领土，以至于我们愿意为了这些领土的完整而互相摧毁，我们用核武器武装自己，我们愿意摧毁整个星球，因为我们如此强烈地相信这些发明的现实。当然，这位来自另一个星系的类人猿会认为这是一种错觉。当然，我们许多人并不这么认为，因为当你身处错觉之中时，那通常是最难识别你正在经历错觉的地方。简而言之，如果我们知道别人在欺骗自己，但以一种
way that might be helpful for them, do we have any obligation to correct that? I think the question is truly asked the question, who is this deception and aid off? Who is the self-deception harming and who is it helping? I think there are certain self-deceptions, you know, in the course of the last 12 months, I've come up with self-deceptions that tell me every month that the end is near, the pandemic is near, that the, you know, liberation is a month away or a few weeks away. I know many family members that have turned to religious beliefs because they have found the pandemic to be so difficult to bear and so and has produced so much grief and suffering. I don't believe it's in my place to disobey people of those self-deceptions, deceptions that in some ways help us get through the day, allow us in some ways to be kind or gentle of people. Certainly,
可能对他们有帮助的方式，我们是否有任何义务去纠正它？我认为这个问题真正问的是，这种欺骗对谁有帮助？这种自我欺骗在伤害谁，在帮助谁？我认为有一些自我欺骗，你知道，在过去的12个月里，我产生了一些自我欺骗，每个月都告诉我末日临近，大流行临近，你知道，解放离我们只有一个月或几周的时间。我知道许多家庭成员转向了宗教信仰，因为他们发现大流行太难忍受，而且产生了太多的悲伤和痛苦。我不认为我有权去打破人们的那些自我欺骗，那些在某种程度上帮助我们度过难关，让我们在某种程度上对人友善或温柔的欺骗。当然，
I think when those deceptions harm us, and especially when they harm other people, that is the time to intervene and to ask, when have these delusions tipped over to being dangerous, how can we dismantle them? Journalist Shankar Vedantam is host of the Hidden Brain podcast. His most recent book is Useful Delusions, the power and paradox of the self-deceiving brain. Shankar, it's always a pleasure to speak with you. Thank you for making time for us. Thank you, Chris. That was my interview with Chris Boyd for the show Think.
我认为当那些欺骗伤害我们时，尤其是当它们伤害他人时，那是干预并询问的时候，这些错觉何时变成了危险的，我们如何瓦解它们？记者尚卡尔·维丹塔姆是《隐藏的大脑》播客的主持人。他最近的著作是《有用的错觉：自我欺骗大脑的力量与悖论》。尚卡尔，和你交谈总是很高兴。谢谢你为我们抽出时间。谢谢你，克里斯。那是我为节目《思考》与克里斯·博伊德进行的采访。
I'm really grateful to Chris and the whole team at KERA for the wonderful conversation. Learn more about that show at think.keRA.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, Andrew Chadwick, Kristen Wong, and Laura Quarelle. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Bill Messler.
我非常感谢克里斯和KERA的整个团队进行的精彩对话。在think.keRA.org了解更多关于该节目的信息。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、奥特姆·巴恩斯、瑞安·卡茨、安德鲁·查德威克、克里斯汀·王和劳拉·夸雷尔。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是比尔·梅斯勒。
Bill is my co-author on useful delusions. In fact, he's the one who suggested we write this book. Over the course of several years of collaboration where we worked closely together, I got to know Bill very well. He's not just a terrific science journalist and writer, but one of the kindest and most upright people I know. And I'm not just saying that because it's a useful delusion. Thank you Bill. We'll be back next week with another episode of Hidden Brain. I'll be back in the host seat. To learn more about useful delusions and to read an excerpt of the book, go to hiddenbrain.org slash books. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
比尔是我《有用的错觉》的合著者。事实上，是他建议我们写这本书的。在几年的合作过程中，我们密切合作，我非常了解比尔。他不仅是一位出色的科学记者和作家，而且是我认识的最善良、最正直的人之一。我这么说不仅仅是因为这是一个有用的错觉。谢谢你，比尔。下周我们将带着《隐藏的大脑》的另一集回来。我将回到主持人的位置。要了解更多关于《有用的错觉》并阅读该书的节选，请访问hiddenbrain.org斜杠books。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。